okay Welcome to our latest in this live
stream series I'm Zach Weissmuller with
my colleague here Nick Gillespie and uh
today uh I am thrilled to have just one
of my favorite people joining us uh he's
a clear thinker an extremely
entertaining podcaster a dad a
successful entrepreneur the man the
legend
Camille Foster thanks for joining us
thank you for everything I don't I don't
think he's that great but yeah that's
good to see you you forgot to say sex
symbol exactly yeah well you know uh
Camille this is an honest truthful
Outlook you know this isn't one of your
cable news programs
so I I want to get a little uh meta this
afternoon and talk uh what it about what
what's like uh what it is that you like
to talk about and to set that up I'm
just going to play an intro to your
podcast the fifth column which I have no
doubt many of today's viewers are quite
familiar with
[Music]
this columns
and welcome back to another exciting
installment of the fifth column podcast
this is your weekly rhetorical assault
in the news cycle of people that made it
and occasionally ourselves I'm Camille
Foster I do various things at free think
and today we had a delayed start because
apparently there's this this really
interesting compelling and grossing
profile of
so uh you know your your weekly
rhetorical assault on the news cycle and
the people who make it you like to talk
about media and in fact I think of fifth
column largely as a media criticism
podcast that'd be correct why is that
such a foundational aspect of what you
do
well I think media literacy is important
uh in a free Society we need access to
information the people who bring us
information
um at play an important role uh but they
need to be held accountable and Citizens
need to be equipped with the tools to be
able to discern what makes sense and
what doesn't make sense I think there's
an analogy that I've used of someone
who's like going down into a mine which
you know this is very filthy difficult
work they bring up something they kind
of dust it off a little bit and it sort
of seems to Sheen as a Sheen and it's
yellow but is it gold or is it fool's
gold and making a determination between
those two things is not always easy but
it is definitely worth doing
um and I'd like to think that that's
what we try to do at the fifth column
with a great deal of levity we operated
a couple different speeds sometimes it's
very sober and serious at other times it
is completely ridiculous and Kareem's
out of control but either way it's worth
your time and your money so subscribe oh
yeah always be uh selling right what is
the word what's the worst job that you
had uh because you are talking as if
you've been into mine
I've never been actually I'm sure I've
been in a mine I've never worked in a
mine the worst job I've had was probably
a clerical gig I took it like 14 15.
yeah I understand the physical labor
that I've had to do has always been kind
of rewarding you know like swinging an
ax to chop wood or something like that
it's it's fun it's great you get to be
outside what how did you get how did you
get uh you know kind of hip to the idea
that like the news is the news is raw
material or it's pre-packaged in a way
that you know you as the consumer the
reader whatever has to really do the
work to figure out what this means and
where you know where does it come from
what's it mean and where is it going
yeah I think it's probably uh Carl
Sagan's [ __ ] detector kit
um it's actually not [ __ ] I think he
uses the word baloney but [ __ ] is
inappropriate
um word as well
um and I believe I was introduced to
that in one of his books it might have
been uh the the one about uh I'm
forgetting the title at the moment but
that was one of the first things that I
remember
um kind of
touching this like skeptical bone that I
have in my body but at the same time you
know I was raised in a in a very uh
devout household and was surrounded by
literature
um and specifically he had to read a lot
of uh the biblical account and can
distinctly remember the first time I
encountered like the Downing Thomas and
this notion that there is kind of it's
blessed to be someone who believes
without seeing and that never sat well
with me yeah because it just doesn't
seem like uh like a good quality to have
so I'm a bit of a skeptic but I think in
a very
productive sense I think it's in it's in
necessary to have a kind of a skeptical
disposition so long as it's productive I
think that's very different from
cynicism yeah uh you're also very
libertarian how did you how did you come
to you know so you're skeptical to begin
with that can lead in a lot of
directions but then you're also
libertarian how did that come about uh I
could say with some certainty that the
very first
libertarian thing that I read uh was
probably Milton Friedman's capitalism
and freedom I was in college and someone
said to me during a conversation Camille
you're far too bright to be a Democrat
and I don't know how he got me to this
book but he did and in the introduction
to the book there's this treatment of
Kennedy's speech where he talks about he
says ask not what your country could do
for you ask what you can do for your
country and Milton Friedman goes on to
explain that neither side of this is
consistent with the ideals of a free man
in a free society and goes on to
articulate this vision of free people
working towards their several goals
within a free society and our goal being
to to maintain that free that that kind
of system of freedom and for whatever
reason you know I'm I'm a sophomore
junior in college and I'd never been EX
exposed to that clear distillation of
what Freedom could be ought to be and it
was immediately appealing and resonated
with me and I went on from there to read
a number of other things including
bastiops the law and a couple of other
kind of foundational books and then I
discovered reason and Cato and I started
reading some guy named Nick valespie and
yeah yeah and then all down hell further
radicalized from there well then I found
rothbard and that's what really really
got me going all right well we'll get it
where where did you go to college and
what was what did you major in
University of Maryland College Park I
started as a biochemistry major my
end of my first semester I went home and
started watching C-SPAN like religiously
and I discovered Washington Journal and
I got really hooked and without telling
my mom I changed my major to government
and economics like the very next year
and I didn't actually end up completing
the term in a normal way and after my
second year of college I started a
telecom consulting firm and slowly built
up this lifestyle business and ran that
for about 10 years but I eventually
completed my two degrees in government
economics and that was important but I
think having that kind of protracted
undergraduate experience also gave me an
opportunity to just do a lot of
independent reading and to find and
pursue my interests and to select where
there were elective courses stuff that
was really consistent with what was most
interesting to me and
I think all of that probably contributed
to my my odd development it's
interesting hearing you uh kind of put
skepticism at the center of what you're
doing like what how does that interact
with or I guess inform your politics
yeah well I mean I think I think like
skepticism infallibility are are
critical
foundational pieces of what you need
like the kind of culture of Freedom
um certainly like the notion of free
speech is rooted in this sensibility
that whatever the dominant ideas there
is some New Perspective which might be
heretical today but is ultimately right
and it is vitally important that we
actually have a system and a culture
that is okay with people challenging the
the dominant perspectives that are on
offer and overturning them and that this
is a natural process and I mean I think
even today in our very modern society my
sense is that most learned people
believe we've kind of reached the
definitive end of history and the end of
philosophy that there are no new
inspiring ideas that will be brought to
bear and that there couldn't be anything
that they believe that isn't absolutely
right and true
um it's it's this like thorough going
fundamentalism and it exists on the left
and the right
um but I think people with this kind of
classical liberal event Libertarians
have a much better appreciation of just
how difficult it's been for us to get
where we are and how likely it is that
we're wrong about plenty of things and
the the
ever-present possibility that we could
retrace our steps and go backwards and
fall into something worse and yeah I
think that's I think it all it all kind
of flows together in that way
yeah I'm I'm very worried about the the
retracing the steps and uh maybe we can
talk a little bit more about that in a
second with with as a regards to kind of
your skepticism of narratives that come
to dominate
um politics or media I think a really
good example of that was uh you've been
a guest a couple times on uh your
friends with Barry Weiss who hosts a
podcast called honestly which I I very
much enjoy but you were on there a
couple times
um talking about the so-called Central
Park Karen case
um and I want to play an excerpt from
your first appearance where you kind of
explained your thoughts about all that
um and I want to go from there and just
talk about
how representative it is of the way you
think about much of how the media frames
stories why they do it why it might be a
problem uh so let's play that clip first
all this is happening against the
backdrop of America's racial Reckoning
which is just in its earliest weeks
and during that period you had nightly
protests all over the country and New
York City was certainly no exception
[Music]
more tense clashes around the country
including this standoff at the Barclays
Center in Brooklyn where a police car
burned as officer Peppers there were
demonstrations in front of the mayor's
house in front of City Hall in the
streets of Soho and from what I've
learned about the case
it's hard for me to ignore the
likelihood that the decision to proceed
with this prosecution
against the odds was largely a public
relations stunt
so I mean what why was this case so
interesting to you
um and just what are I guess some of the
lessons you took away from digging a
little deeper into it
well I think the best way to give you
contacts for that is to explain how I
discovered that there was something
worth looking into here fully a year
after this this woman Amy Cooper had her
encounter with a man named Christian
Cooper no relation in Central Park
I was reading a story uh on NBC
um I guess I guess it's just mbc.com
maybe it's nbcnews.com probably that and
somewhere buried in the story about a
lawsuit that she'd filed against her
former employer for wrongful termination
was a couple of lines about this guy
named Jerome Lockett who had had a
previous encounter with Christian Cooper
and the NBC story all it says is that
Jerome Lockett
um that a letter from Jerome Lockett to
NBC News was included in the legal
filing and NBC the article goes on to
say that NBC spoke to Jerome Lockett at
the time that the the attack happened or
the not attack but the encounter
happened and it doesn't provide any
additional detail and I went looking for
any story that they would have written
related to this Jerome Lockett situation
and the the situation with Jerome
Lockett was that Christian Cooper The
Gentle bird watcher who who
recorded Amy Cooper and made her famous
he'd had two physical altercations in
Central Park in the previous four months
at least two that we know of and he
admitted to this in a in a private
context and I found the audio for that
um
and I think if people know that they
probably approach the story about Amy
Cooper and that 30 second video with a
slightly different perspective and the
fact that NBC News had talked to Jerome
Lockett a 30 year old black man who had
an encounter with Christian Cooper that
ended with him having to push him away
from his dog because he felt unsafe
um that they decided not to run this
story
and they never bothered to explain why
they didn't run this story I even
reached out for comment to the editors
and the reporters that were responsible
for interviewing him at the time
um is kind of shocking and what became
more shocking to me was that as I
continued to look around and I talked to
more journalists and I think this is
ultimately there's the human tragedy of
sort of Amy Cooper being pilloried for
something that isn't obviously what
people imagine but the the heart of the
story is that a number of journalists at
media Outlets some conservative and some
liberal
knew about
um the the additional details that there
were other people and that they were too
incurious or too afraid to actually
complicate this story in a way that made
it look like anything other than a crazy
Karen white woman calling the police on
a black man in order to get him murdered
it didn't matter to them that Christian
Cooper had in the weeks prior been
advocating for more law enforcement in
Central Park because he wanted to have
cops there to enforce leash laws he was
not afraid of being murdered by the cops
at least that doesn't suggest those
aren't the actions of someone who
believes they'll be murdered by the cops
um yeah and yeah you know does this kind
of stuff happen sure I think there are
plenty of examples of it and we've seen
lots of examples of rather crummy
moral Clarity moral Clarity is a phrase
that we know now
um motivated reasoning that that is
ostensibly supposed to be journalism but
is anything but
to Christian Cooper's you know credit he
really did not seem to want to pursue
this once it became a media master I
mean now he's got like a Netflix show or
whatever but I was going to say is it
it's inflatable Christian Cooper decided
that he didn't want to participate in
the prosecution and at some point
decided to no longer do media after
having done a lot of media I wouldn't
want to prosecute either if I knew that
when I got up on the stand and was
cross-examined a great deal of things
would be made public that thus far the
media systematically ignored without
focusing on him though like the the
speed with which her employer canned her
and the whole house kind of set in stone
that this is a woman who is you know the
moral equivalent of the woman who uh
said that Emmett Till had whistled at
her it came you know that was the
narrative with capital letters
um how do we guard against that in a
world where there is a rapid response
you know we have all forms of media
everybody has a voice but you know some
voices count for more what you know how
do we slow the the race to the narrative
down in a way so we have better
responses yeah that some voices count
for more and also we have this bizarre
media ecosystem where you've got
algorithms that push stories and uh
journalists journalistic Outlets that
publish stories instantaneously and a
culture wherein we are primed to grab
this 30-second clip devoid of context
and retweet it to all of our followers
and I think the the best thing that we
could do the greatest Safeguard would be
for us to one be more skeptical
dutifully rigorously skeptical
um but two to just develop and maybe
that skeptical muscle is part of this
the appropriate set of cultural
antibodies that allow us to exist in the
world as we find it today like the
current media ecosystem the the current
level of connectedness is something that
we are simply not designed to deal with
um it it manages to play on kind of all
of our like weird cognitive biases in
ways that can be incredibly harmful and
I think it's it's imperative to imagine
that this story that you're reading
about the person who was purportedly the
worst kind of person could be you it
could be that they said something
inelegant and if if you actually care
about the purported Injustice that took
place then you should care enough to
want to know the difference between an
actual crime and an imagined crime
between uh an impoliteness or or a
mistake and someone who is a vehement
racist or an anti-semite like the
difference matters it's not trivial
exactly sounds like a good tee up right
for some of the clips or go ahead well
yeah yeah I mean one thing that I took
from that was
um you know especially the the clip
there makes it clear the context of this
was coming on the heels of the kind of
you know uprisings that were happening
after the the George Floyd killing and
there was all this energy around this
issue and so that's perhaps you know one
lesson for the skeptic to take is when
there's a lot of discussion or energy
around a particular issue and then
stories begin to pop up that just like
very conveniently like further that
maybe that takes that warrants you know
an extra look
um and like like one of the political
narratives that I think we could all
examine right now as we approach the
midterms is and it seems like kind of
the Winds of political change uh might
be coming
um and there's a lot of stories a lot of
narratives about what exactly that means
one of the framings uh that you're
hearing especially from Democrats is
that this is a bunch of fascistic
election deniers on the brink of seizing
power
um the reality might be a little more
complicated than that uh but let's play
this clip from uh Hillary Clinton uh to
get a sense of the message that
Democrats are putting forward right now
this is for
um like a kind of pack that she is is
behind uh it's like it's a fundraising
appeal that this is the message that she
feels is appropriate to be putting out
right now extremists already have a plan
to literally steal the next presidential
election and then making a secret of it
so
um
what's your reaction to
the discussion around you know election
Security fraud and the upcoming midterms
anyone who's been paying attention
ought to know that since the around the
2000 election where good gorby Bush
which ended up in in the courts in order
to get decided there's been growing
skepticism in both political parties
about the the
trustworthiness of our electoral process
and we've seen kind of a one-upsmanship
like in every single national election
cycle in the midterms as well this year
with people increasingly suggesting that
the outcome is dubious that the other
side is cheating that they're going to
cheat they'll definitely cheat and you
can tell who is going to generally you
can tell who's going to be the most
full-throated and decrying the outcome
of the election based on who wins and
who loses
um except Donald Trump is the exception
to the rule here because he was still
insisting that the election had been
kind of mucked with
um yeah he never accepted even when he
won oh yeah because he he was like I
would have won like with 54 of the vote
if they had counted all the ballots yeah
so he's he definitely has kind of
perfected this entire thing in the worst
sorts of ways but this is hardly alien
to Democrats and Hillary Clinton seems
to be indulging in the same thing and uh
I mean look it's it's not as though
there aren't extremists who are
articulating their perspective on what
ought to happen on how elections ought
to be taken on on reinstalling the
president the former president of the
United States He himself continues to
insist that this ought to happen but
exaggerating the degree to which this is
a thing referring to some marginal
figure in the conservative movement in
the fringes of the conservative movement
and suggesting that there is this bold
plan to steal the next election is
precisely what democracy Kratz would
call this if Donald Trump was doing or
any of his acolytes it is dangerous
rhetoric that that increases
um concern and skepticism about the
quality of our institutions at a time
when what we should really be doing is
talking about transparency like trying
to build trust and we're not doing that
and that is that's deeply concerning
yeah Hillary's uh that group is called
the uh indivisible or indivisible and
she refers to them as the indivisibles
but uh you know their their catchphrases
crushed the coup yes like a violent
image
which is itself a violent takeover of
the government
you have talked uh you know about how
yeah I mean there's no question Trump is
Trump is like the you know the Pavarotti
of this right he can he can play he can
sing any song you want to hear about
election fraud and his followers people
like Carrie Lake who's probably going to
become governor of Arizona is an insane
sycophant of trump you know but then
there's people like Stacy Abrams the who
lost the gubernatorial race in uh in uh
in Georgia a few years ago and has never
conceded
um what what are your thoughts about the
way she represents a kind of democratic
mode of challenging the outcomes of
clearly legitimate elections yeah no I
mean Stacy Abrams is a is a incredibly
interesting character in American
politics this is a woman who has been
sainted despite having never really won
anything in arthropolitics
um she's most famous for losing an
election insisting that she lost by a
fraud and now several years later we
know launching an incredible perhaps the
most expensive in the history of Georgia
legal challenge
um let me pull up uh I pulled some clips
from this recent Politico article on
that I just want to just to give
everyone a sense of how expensive and
and failed this operation was
um more than 25 million dollars over two
years on legal fees mostly on a single
case with the largest amount going to
the self-described boutique law firm of
the candidates campaign chairwoman
um
the judge who ruled against her said the
challenge practices violate neither the
Constitution nor the Voting Rights Act
um it's the slam dunk
you know what what she had claimed after
she uh lost to Kemp uh 50 to 48 was that
thousands of Voters dispr fortunate
number of whom or people of color were
effectively disenfranchised by overly
restrictive voting rules so yeah I mean
what what message does that send about
you know trustworthiness of our
institutions
um and all that money spent to come up
with very little uh in at the end of the
day look it's it's impossible for me to
read her mind I can't know whether or
not there was you know deliberate fraud
here I can't know whether or not she was
acting in bad faith or any of that other
stuff I don't need to just get to to
speculate about her motives but what we
can say is that it is incredibly
unseemly to be enriching to the tune of
tens of millions of dollars your very
good friend and campaign manager while
you are drumming up all of these rather
wild
um conspiracies about what happened in
the election I mean she they even
included in the original in the original
legal firing which was incredibly
complicated and long
um voluminous legal filing claims about
election machines that weren't acting
properly but they had been hacked in
some way shape or form because people
were trying to push Abrams but that it
would switch to Kemp I mean this is this
is hypocrisy that would be risible if it
wasn't so consequential
there's you know the the connection that
I see here between what we're talking
about in media coverage and
um you know all the kind of innuendo
swirling around elections is just this
decreasing trust being able to trust you
know what you see being able to trust uh
out uh supposed outcomes and and part of
this you know you were mentioning
earlier this confusion that is being
created by I don't know digital media in
general our inability to cope with
information overload and so forth and
and now layer on top of that you know
the ability to manipulate uh for you
know purposely manipulate media both in
just by clipping things out of context
and just like outright old spring clips
and we we did pull a couple of examples
of that from various political
operatives that have engaged in that
this first one here is uh Jill Biden
this was a recent one doctor Dr Joe bug
Dr Phil my apologies and uh this is a uh
just you know everyone this is a
doctored clip uh so be forewarned
realize that
even illuminate
Delicacies are made with love
that the most rewarding gifts are those
we give
[Music]
and then there's also this one that I
saw recently this is
um from a kind of political operative uh
named Bubba Prague on Twitter and this
one actually earned him the uh stay
informed tag from Twitter and a little
uh you know uh correction on the sidebar
um this is incredibly obviously fake to
me um I don't know why people fell for
it but it's got like 40 000 likes on
Twitter and you can kind of see how he
frames it he's like riding that line
between
um you know
trying to say that it's satire but
actually I want to also dupe as many
people as I can with this so uh let's
play this real quick this raid happened
and it was a raid it's not a raid I mean
with all due respect it of course was a
raid it was not a raid they were serving
process in accordance with the laws and
Constitution of the United States and
the State of Florida they did it with
Integrity they did it with honor
like problems of believe that I think
but um
fascinating isn't it because we now have
I mean this was you know as somebody who
was writing in the 90s about the rise of
the internet and generally lowered uh
technology lowered price and cost for
technology suddenly you had everybody
became able to basically do really good
fakes and that obviously is only getting
better and better
um I don't know I've I tend to find a
lot of this stuff incredibly liberating
uh because this is a millennial
Millennia old impulse by people to
recontextualize and reconfigure official
discourse into whatever they wanted I
mean in the Middle Ages you could be in
various uh principalities this was true
in England if you were caught writing
down with the king's said in a public
setting and you weren't officially his
emanuensis you could be killed because I
wanted to control the you know the
discourse right so at a certain level
like I'm all for this kind of stuff and
the more ludicrous and the better it is
you know the like the the more
believable it is the better
um but it does lead to cynicism right
where you like you cannot believe
anything that you see you really have to
check you know you got to check out
whether your mother loves you and you
know whether the footage of her telling
you you're a piece of [ __ ] is real or
not well that's the own the old
journalism victim and and I think you
know I think you make it a really great
Point Nick I I had a conversation with
someone about education uh the other day
and they were saying something about
these aai
um softwares that can write entire
essays for you and as they get better
this creates a real conundrum for
schools because I mean you're assign an
essay to a kid and they just use the
algorithm it writes them the thing and
they get a great perfect score and my
feeling about this is you know it's easy
to kind of fetishize the tech and to
think about this as this intractable
problem will never be able to solve but
the reality is that there's two things
going on one that we've been here before
and you could always hire someone to
kind of write a paper for you you
probably need to the extent this becomes
a widespread phenomena maybe you need to
change the model we evolve and we do
things a little bit differently and the
second thing is that our countermeasures
to these things are improving markedly
every single day and there are some
really impressive efforts underway to do
things like put
um digital content on chain so that
there is a clear chain of custody and
you have a sensibility about
authenticity and entire organizations
that I suspect will exist at some point
in the near future to help verify
content and to verify the verifiers and
yes that is the world we'll be in but in
a very real sense it's it's a world that
we've always lived in when there were
only three media sources the capacity of
the state to lie to you
um in various ways existed it was real
and tangible and I would say that it was
almost certainly greater than today is
it hard to know things sure I suspect
that's it's complicated there's a lot of
things going on Martin gury's book
Revolt of the public is really
informative on that but
um it's always been hard to know things
and for a lot of us I think we probably
weren't unaware of the degree to which
we were being fed uh oversimplified
narratives or outright falsehoods that
benefited someone
um which shouldn't make you cynical it
should make you skeptical and being
skeptical and concerned about what's
true because the truth matters means
that you should should get serious do
more reading read more than the headline
don't share [ __ ] that might turn out to
be fake because that is embarrassing
right
uh you know uh Jeff on that point of the
essays uh my ex-wife and her husband who
are both full professors uh at Chapman
University I was uh went to dinner with
them the other night and they were
talking about this because College
professors now use a variety of programs
where they check essays to see if
they've been plagiarized there's a
database that they check again but they
say the AI stuff because they have a lot
of Chinese students from mainland China
whose English is not good
um and the one way that one way that
they know there's something up is when
the grammar is perfect because
the words may not make much sense right
but if they're grammatically perfect so
yeah this is kind of like a man in the
High Castle world you know where they're
selling fake replicas of the old west
and if they're too good you know it's a
fake but it's the only option you had
before that was Michael Moynihan reading
your thing yeah to find some weird
Cadence in there and say oh you're a
plagiarist it's uh you know it's it's
amazing I think a lot going back to the
90s when you know when email became was
the killer app and then there were
viruses and like you know and you you
know email you didn't know about this or
that and it's like we took care of that
problem you don't hear about computer
viruses that's right the way that you
did Circ in 1995 or 96. yeah and I think
that the the
perspective here on offer is that
hysteria probably isn't warranted but
concern is fine and there's a real
question about who will win the arms
race and whether or not things may get
out of control before we have
appropriate Solutions and remedies but
there are appropriate Solutions and
remedies and it is the case that we have
kind of sort of been here before in some
respects and I think in general with
most things if we could just bring down
the temperature a bit
um the the closing argument in the
midterms for both the left and the right
is those other people are complete
monsters who will destroy everything you
hold dear if they win power this is the
end of America either it's a cabal of
groomers who want to mutilate your
children's genitals or it's a cabal of
fascists who hate everyone who isn't
white and are going to put you into a
camp and grind you into meat and feed
you to their animals it's it's all
Preposterous and absurd but it doesn't
mean there aren't reasons for concern
but and I think the thing I'm most
concerned about at the moment is the
fact that there is just this this
bottomless cynicism and hopelessness and
an inability to trust one another and we
have to live together that is that's
just the case
too I mean the the P let's blame the
people who are most responsible for this
which of course are not not one of us
none of the three of us right or
Libertarians but uh exactly the
fetterman Oz debate clip because this is
who the two major parties right you have
all the money all the power all the
institutional might these are the
apparitions that they're coughing up to
you know run in the the greatest you
know world's greatest deliberative body
or something like that
tonight that you support fracking that
you've always supported fracking but
there is that 2018 interview that you
said quote I don't support fracking at
all so how do you square the two
oh I I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking geez so I mean talk
about cynicism I mean it's hard not to
be cynical when you look at the
Pennsylvania ranks you have better men
who clearly has you know some serious
impairments going against a celebrity
doctor
supplements to people I mean and then
you have people you practice
inflation in the context of crude attack
I mean it's like what yeah David sorota
is a uh you know writer of the nation
activist work for Bernie Sanders saying
here's a truth few will say aloud but I
will being a senator is America's
easiest job
yay or nay this notion that John
Federman can't do that job because he's
recovering from a health event is
moronic and everyone immediately I mean
you don't really get much more cynical
about politics why don't we have like a
hundred chickens yeah you know they're
pecking at like cards go all the way
right go all the way it's opportunistic
cynicism there though I don't I don't
think he actually believes that my
suspicion is if we look he probably has
some tweet about Herschel Walker being a
dangerous idiot who shouldn't be
anywhere near the levers of power which
I think is probably true yeah but but
it's important when you're only willing
to say it when it is to your advantage
to say it
um and I think that's actually what's
going on there
um but yeah look I I'd say this I've
been saying a number of bad things about
cynicism it is appropriate to be cynical
about most of your elected officials
they are bad self-interested cowards who
aren't really willing to do anything
that might get them into trouble if they
actually think that it's the right thing
to do they won't vote against their
party they'll they'll write a completely
innocuous letter about Ukraine and then
moments later when it seems politically
in unacceptable to their to their
counterparts in Congress they'll say ah
that was a mistake we're really sorry
but what is it why did you write the
letter at all why did you sign it why
did you think this was appropriate to
notify the media again about if 24 hours
later actually eight hours later the
thing wasn't going to matter at all
they're just unprincipled people that
can't be taken seriously but how how
this this is a big question I think
particularly for Libertarians because
you know the libertarian rhetoric is
that all government uh you know are
oftentimes the stereotypical uh
libertarian message is all government
all politicians are not just in in a you
know stupid uh and incompetent but
they're evil uh everything is bad
um is that a message is that a message
that helps anything or does it just
compound the problem and how do
Libertarians talk about governance
policy the individuals you know who are
going to make this up in a way that
doesn't just give in to the rancus form
of nihilism where it really doesn't
matter who's in office if you believe
that they're always going to be terrible
what what difference does it make well I
I wouldn't say that it doesn't matter
who's in office
um but I I do have kind of some
heuristics and stratagems like I prefer
divided government so the Democrats
control Congress I probably want a
republican in the house in the White
House and that's you know strategic
thinking maybe that doesn't always lead
to the best outcomes but I think maybe
the way to look at it is the government
is endlessly corruptable which is very
different than saying like the
institutions don't matter I think that
the institutions are actually important
I think our Civic Norms can be very
important in in certain respects
um when they're healthy when they're
kind of Pros free speech and
anti-censorship when there is a kind of
visceral reaction to the notion that
some some Corporation will be
coordinating with government to shut
people up who are saying things that
might be unpopular because you just know
that that isn't the way that we do
things here I think it's important for
us to cultivate a respect for that I
think it's important even to be to have
an admiration for the uniqueness of the
American experiment and I'm I'm a weird
like a narco-capitalist bozo but I know
how unusual it is for there to be a
country that is founded on the kinds of
ideals that America imperfectly is
rooted in
um and those are ideas that are worth
defending uh and that are worth
celebrating and I think that the reality
is that the personification of those
ideas is not to be found in the halls of
Congress
um and on any given day it's probably
not in the Supreme Court it's in our
associations with one another the way
that we pursue our own interests the
businesses that we build the coalitions
that we forge on our own and if we can
keep in mind that the goal of all of the
governance stuff ought to be to enable
that flourishing to allow us to to do
and build things that are better than
the things that existed before then I
think we'll be in a very good place but
if we imagine that either the
revivalists who insist that what we need
to do is Retreat back to a time in the
past when everything was perfect or the
redistributionists who insist the future
is hopeless the best we can do is take
some stuff from those people and give it
to you then we will lose ultimately
um and unfortunately I think that's
where we find ourselves with in fact the
revivalists have become reduced
redistributionists as well explicitly
and openly which is another problem no
I'm curious if you think that there is
is like a clear like libertarian
friendly antidote to both the cynicism
and the confusion that is happening in
our media and politics right now I mean
there is the libertarian party which is
in some of these Senate races and
covering the spread in like Georgia and
Nick and I did a documentary about the
Takeover that happened there
um that you know Marty's having an
identity crisis at the moment yes you're
right it's having identity crisis and it
was before these kids took over as well
it's just a different sort of identity
crisis well it has an identity crisis
yeah yeah I'm curious like what do you
what you make of that identity crisis
and what you hope comes out of it and
what you hope Libertarians will be
offering it doesn't even have to be you
know Big L Libertarians but what are the
things that um you know you think
Libertarians could be putting on offer
that's just not out there right now in
either party or kind of the general
discourse I've I've been generally
optimistic about some of the trends that
I've seen happening I can I can still
remember when there was a story in the
New York Times about the libertarian
moment which I'm confident Nick was
profiled in and mentioned it
um because he was part of that uh and I
was excited you know you had you had Ron
Paul and you had uh Gary Johnson
even Rand Paul that's right he was on
the cover of yeah you know the story was
has the libertarian moment finally
arrived and it was yeah and Rand is
complicated complicated Legacy in that
regard but in either case they were
pushing a certain set of ideas that were
in fact resonating with a wider and
wider swath of the country and My Hope
was that after four years of Donald
Trump and a great deal of
dissatisfaction and a rather
lackluster crop of candidates on the
left to oppose him that there might be a
real opportunity for a moderate
establishment even I know that's a dirty
word
um libertarian party to appeal to a lot
of normies who might not be interested
in or even prepared to have a
conversation about all pro all the roads
being private today or abolishing all
private schools tomorrow I know it's
shocking for some of us to hear as as
near and dear as some of those concepts
are to my heart that moderation and
pragmatism is actually a good thing and
it's helped to create the world that we
live in today which is undoubtedly
indisputably Freer in so many important
ways than the one that we lived in a
couple hundred years ago and the fact
that pragmatism helped get us there
should say something about the
importance of there being a political
movement in a political institution that
operates within the electoral system
within those confines to try and bring
more and more Americans into the fold
and I think at the moment the party has
adopted this kind of shock and awe
strategy of kind of of meaning their way
to Victory and outraging people who are
both outside of the movement and in the
movement of being incredibly polarizing
and this isn't to a person I mean I've
had conversations with folks like Dave
Smith and I think Dave is a is a good
guy who is smart and bright and
interesting and has a tremendous amount
to offer I wish that the people who are
around him and that are operating the
party would do so with a little bit more
thoughtfulness there is a tremendous
opportunity here and I think mocking
people when they die which is generally
something that isn't regarded as a okay
whatever the circumstances mocking their
children after they've died generally
not acceptable these are probably just
not great strategies will it will it go
viral will you get a bunch of negative
press sure is that what you want even to
the extent that's how you could
potentially win I don't want to win that
way
um but I also don't think you'll win I
think ultimately you'll burn in ignominy
and we don't need that we're already
marginal at the moment I don't need to
be notorious also
I want to give Camille the I know
Camille has to run soon there were a
couple questions I just want to throw up
here for you Camille
um one was here I'll just put on the
screen I think there's one about the age
of consent that we ought to go to a
meeting oh my goodness
I'm talking about moderation
weigh in on that uh Camille Across
America there are many students of
Friedman and Ron Paul since they won't
sell out for votes how do we amplify
their voices so I I guess just asking
I I that might get to the question of
you know pragmatism versus Purity
um like if there's someone like a Dave
Smith who you know Fashions himself as
like I'm I'm carrying the torch of Ron
Paul
um
you know how how far can that approach
get you do you think I mean I think it
can get you incredibly far I mean I
think that the the stuff that they've
been doing
um with respect to to foreign policy
um with respect to criminal justice
um is is incredibly valuable it's
worthwhile to continue doing that work
um I think there are profound
disagreements about the appropriate
approach to addressing some of the weird
social stuff that's happening a lot of
the controversies in schools whether or
not it's appropriate to ban certain
things out of existence about some of
these gender debates
um but to the extent Libertarians can be
a
a fount of Reason in these troubled
times that they can help to Foster
healthy conversations I have to tell you
that outside of elite circles where the
the fire is burning the most intensely
there is a legion there are Legions of
Americans I should say who are
interested in moderate voices who are
interested in saying Alternatives who
want people who they can just say God
you seem normal and nice I could
actually pull the lever for you like
they're making a decision between
fetterman and Dr Oz
and you want to give them like meme
Warrior as the alternative right I think
we could probably do better than that
again it's just a strategy maybe try to
do both things a little bit I don't know
how do you uh how how do you how did all
time not a question but that is that is
uh laudable you sound like a good decent
human yeah
um how how do you think about
de-prioritizing politics I mean you know
for me one of the reasons why I'm
libertarian is because I dislike
politics I wanted to be in as small a
space as possible because it is zero sum
on some fundamental level there are
certain things that are going to be
decided where you know 50 plus one vote
makes the other 50 minus one vote eat it
and you just got to live that way so you
want to keep that minimal there was a
you know there were various periods of
the 90s was an example of this where you
know there was a kind of consensus at
the end of the Cold War at the beginning
of the internet you know the internet
and economic expansion politics wasn't
that important let's go out and roam the
world and have fun and do interesting
stuff that has been clawed back you know
and it started probably you know with uh
the 2000 election certainly 911 the
economic crisis you know suddenly we
live in a world now where you know God
is God is dead but but politics Reigns
Supreme how do we start to
re-calibrate you know so that we're
talking more about culture Econo you
know business lived experience and you
know voluntary aspects of Our Lives
rather than politics I don't know
precisely
um my own approach to this is to remain
optimistic and to believe that's
possible to kind of come back from the
brink because we've dealt with things
that are far more difficult than this in
the past
um and to be determined to be involved
in the system and in the process and to
try always to get beyond the the most
controversial
aspects of the debate if uh you know
we're having an argument about abortion
it's probably best that we're not having
it at the margins of whether it should
be completely outlawed or whether or not
Mom should be able to have an abortion
at you know nine minutes before she
gives birth like that's not going to be
very productive and if that's the only
conversation we have we're working at
Cross purposes and I think in a similar
way
um there's questions about what public
education ought to look like if the
argument is between the 1619 project and
you know some America first version of
History like that's not going to be
particularly good either
um so we've we've got to find not a
middle ground but some common ground
we've got to find ways to to address the
actual problem and I think you know when
we're having arguments about whether or
not uh uh propaganda is being taught in
the schools and ultimately know that the
schools aren't really teaching kids much
of anything
um that that is a more severe problem
and then it suggests that we're having
these debates completely disconnected
from the things that actually matter
with respect to the stuff that that we
ostensibly care about if we care about
kids and we care about them becoming
well-informed individuals thoughtful
Skeptics who can contribute in a
meaningful way to the polity
um then the way to do that is with a
functional school system and I'd say
school choice ought to have always taken
priority over these Preposterous
ideological battles so you're
objectively Pro groomer got it
exactly and it's reductive as thinking
like that that's going to get us taken
it's going to take us far it's going to
take us to the Moon Yeah Yeah Camille
thanks for joining us I know you got to
run soon let me leave you with these
final two thoughts from our commenters
maybe Libertarians can put out there a
charismatic candidate who never flies
coach that's an interesting idea it's a
finer point on it uh Camille Foster
and you obviously would do as well as Dr
Oz or Federer fetterman is a seasoned
politician so yeah well this is true
he's had some difficult he's had a
difficult year and probably should have
pulled out of the race it's it's yeah
yeah
no no comment I have to talk to my wife
about 2024 she is the decider and chief
okay yeah okay well good luck with that
thank you for uh joining us thanks guys
I appreciate it talk soon you bet
well I guess now we should just talk
[ __ ] about Camille but
are there other questions that we should
uh engage in here uh let's see one
person asks here
um Can there ever be peace with Chris
Ruffo
um referencing our our live stream from
last week
um I think there can be peace with Chris
Ruffo I think there is probably not ever
going to be agreement uh at least on a
wide range of topics with Chris rupo the
reason we wanted to bring him on here to
talk was I had produced this documentary
about Florida's stop woke act and
Camille was kind of getting into that uh
near the end here about
well are we going to spend our time
fighting over whether a curriculum
should be centered around Nicole Hannah
Jones's 16-19 project or you know some
sort of patriotically correct project
devised by you know the DeSantis team or
something or are we going to offer some
sort of alternative Vision where people
have much more ability to select their
own
um education choice and we want to apply
that kind of thinking to just about
every realm of life and so that's just a
fundamental difference that we have with
somebody like Chris Ruffo so I
appreciate him coming on but I'm not
gonna you know be able to make I'm only
middle ago so far uh towards towards
that well and I I you know I think the
the question is like one of uh you know
what does it mean to live in a
pluralistic and a tolerant Society where
you know you I you don't have we don't
have to agree with him obviously but he
also needs to respect our rights to
teach you know our children the way we
want and we Accord him the same right
and you know that it seems to me like a
very clear and compelling case that
there are going to be many different
ways in which people want to talk about
American history where have they want to
talk about uh you know any given matter
or even what school should be teaching
broadly speaking and um it you know it
it shouldn't be complicated really like
he's free to teach his kids the way they
want and you know and attract more and
more people
um and you and I would have difference
of opinions and then you throw in other
people and like you know let it let a
thousand flowers bloom on that and
pretty much on on every possible issue
I I agree
um another thing that
um Camille brought up that I thought
might be worth discussing a little bit
more is the idea that
um there are there are some emerging
technological solutions to some of the
confusion that we were talking about and
some of the inability to tell what is
real and and what is not real and that
is kind of the promise of blockchain I
mean Nick you recently interviewed
Balaji srinivasan who talks uh really
eloquently about a kind of chain of
custody over information and I do think
that we we are that need is increasingly
urgent because what I'm concerned about
mostly is the kind of memory holding
that happens routinely where people do
stealth edits or pretend like something
that ever happened we have the Wayback
machine which helps archive some of that
but that's not perfect some Melissa's
even got their Twitter feeds you know
Exempted from that and so
um and and I and when you think about
you know uh even like classic Works
being kind of of revised to take out
problematic material I think it is
really important to have a record of how
things were because that is you know the
ability to rewrite history is obviously
a big concern for for anyone and not
least of all Libertarians yeah I totally
agree and this is where we've reached a
point you know it's under you know on
some level the impulse is understandable
either that something is so hideous in
the past that you want to
you know kind of wipe it out so that we
never have to contemplate it again or
you want to control the present you know
to crib from uh Orwell you want to
control the the present by controlling
the past but that is something you know
I think uh the term that Camille used
was cultural antibodies like you know
these these ideas we need a a resilient
system where we're willing to look at
what's happened in the past or even
what's happening now
kind of honestly and openly and deal
with our failures as well as our
successes in the past and and
recognizing that it's a process but I
agree um you know it's also true that a
lot of uh digital technology and I'm
thinking or even in terms of things like
radio which doesn't leave much of a
trace uh but uh television you know
modern technology oftentimes of races
its own past
um you know partly like a lot of TV
shows in the 50s just disappeared
because they were either you know
performed live or the tapes that they
were taped on got taped over you know
things like that
um the historical record is is really
important and we I think we've been
shortchanging it for a very long time
another comment here
um CRT is a combination of sexual
Marxism and racial Marxism it uses every
racial and sexual variation as a weapon
for collectivist power struggles so this
is like
um the rhetoric that you hear a lot uh
anytime you get into this debate around
conversations that people are having
about race and gender right now
um I I personally feel there's a lot to
criticize in
um terms of how like you know
intersectional Theory and the way that
uh these things are applied in like
diversity seminars I think is very is
often very clumsy and counterproductive
but
um this Theory there's this you know
that this this overarching theory that
people try to advance that it's some um
like coordinated Marxist plot and that
is where I just think it gets a little
bit dangerous but you have to take these
things you know one at a time you can't
lump it all together and when you kind
of catastrophized thing then that is how
you
authoritarian intervention because
suddenly have this emergency and we need
to get these special powers to people
down on the bad thing that is
yeah this is the ironically it's a
Marxist or Marxist influence theorist
Giorgio agamban the Italian social
theorist who talks about states of
exception right and that modern
governance particularly in Liberal
democracies is very prone to people
getting whipped up and then saying in
order to preserve a liberal democracy
where we have individual rights and
civil liberties and things like that we
have to suspend them because of this
intense threat and it could be 911 it
could be the economic crisis it could be
covid
um and you end up inscribing like in
that comment I have to say I mean I
appreciate the person sending it but
it's nuts to think that there is a
Marxist kind of conspiracy or then also
to be focusing on racial and sexual
categories
um as if you know Marxism is predicated
upon the idea that there are groups
there are classes that are always at
odds with one another and that you know
everything is a Twilight light struggle
where one will win and the other will
lose that is one way of looking at the
world which was rejected by the world
and it's bizarre to me that in many ways
it's conservative critics of so-called
critical race Theory or Marxism are the
ones who are keeping alive Marxist
analysis we need something better than
that
um I do think it's you know we we are in
a time where you know for some of the
reasons that we talked about in all of
this all of the kind of verities all of
the truths that we took for you know
granted that there are men and women
that there are blacks and whites Etc
like those are eroding not because of
some evil cabal but because we're I
think we're more sophisticated and
interested in individualism and
speciation and things like that but for
many people the idea that these basic
categories are morphing or changing is
terrifying and they want to stop the
movement of the world and say no this is
the way it it always has been and always
must be otherwise Madness lies ahead and
that's just not a way that that is not a
a way to create a productive and you
know positive future it's it's it's you
know reactionary by definition and it
doesn't it doesn't get us anywhere
except into a worse version of an
imagined past that we thought was so
great
and I wonder if to wrap up the stream
Nick if you might talk about
um this this Terror that people have of
that shifting ground and kind of what
we've been talking about the confusion
that all the fakery and all the kind of
manipulative media that is out there and
and the cynicism in our politics what
would you say is
um like the Liberty part of the
libertarian antidote to that are like
what messages do you think Libertarians
um could offer to help clear that fog of
confusion or give people just something
else to aim for rather than what is
being served up in say the Pennsylvania
Senate race yeah I mean it's you know
first and this isn't particularly
libertarian but echoing what uh Camille
was talking about the the centrality of
kind of media literacy or you know and I
actually it's not kind of a media
literacy I would say it's you know
critical thinking
um is a basic component and that's what
our schools should be teaching is like
how do you create people who are more
likely to be able to kind of analyze
things and come to their own conclusions
that's like the core project of our
should be the core project of our
educational system as opposed to making
good citizens or making good workers or
something like that you know we don't
want compliant people we want people who
are independently minded it is wearying
and I you know I say this as I was like
a real utopian in the 90s and I and I
still remain that I mean I'm optimistic
about the future and I think you know
today is not just better than 200 years
ago but in most ways it's better than 20
years ago
um and I think that you know continues
to proceed a pace even if we never want
to discuss that but I think what
Libertarians you know have first off is
a a true optimism and a belief in the
individual that individuals left to
their own devices and you know armed
with a little bit of resources and a
little bit of analytical skill uh which
most of us have and most of us develop
over time are pretty good at figuring
out how to live an interesting
productive life that is social and
functional and kind of you know
Community oriented it's a you know very
few of us are like you know inwardly
looking kind of narcissists who just
want to run the world for our own
benefit we're not like that we're not
designed to be like that and we don't
end up that way so I think that's part
of the libertarian message is one of
optimism and belief in individuals that
you know it's tough It's hard but we're
pretty good at figuring out how to live
a meaningful life and coming up with
interesting stuff
um I think the other thing and this is
something that I think Libertarians
including myself have spent you know
years you know kind of knocking down
institutions both public and private or
public sector and private sector
um and what we need to do is to kind of
really come up with start talking more
and more about examples of places where
things are going well and looking at why
what are the underlying institutions the
networks of Association the temperaments
or mindsets of people and how do we
broaden the scope of freedom of
individuals being able to choose more in
their life this is you know right out of
mises at a Hayek the liberal project was
about people having you know starting
out with very few choices that mattered
in their life to having more and more
choices how do we model that how do we
kind of look at the places where it's
working and build out from there rather
than a kind of nihilistic dismissal of
all Politics as equally bad all policy
is equally bad
um you know we we need to be thinking
more in those terms what about you Zach
what is you know where do you go for
that I agree building on what works and
also I like the idea of um you know
emphasizing the individual and
creativity unleashing creativity
um and Imagination and Innovation like
these are all things that Sprout from
the bottom up and this is something that
sort of seems to be missing and really
has been just squashed a little bit over
the past couple years with the pandemic
and the uh extreme overreach
um and this kind of just flattening of
uh individuals into these these broad
groups that need to be made these large
statistical categories right like if you
have covid you don't have covet Etc I
mean like an urgent need to break all
that down
um and I I'm not hearing it yet uh from
anyone in in politics but you know it
starts with uh you know I believe it's
all it's all bottom up and it does start
with with the culture and hopefully we
can uh push towards that yeah if I might
uh add you know as you're talking I'm
also thinking like you you do this
automatically and take it for granted I
know I try to focus myself on this but
like this is where an understanding of
history is really important I am you
know my grandparents came to the United
States all four of them in the mid 19
teens my parents grew up during the
Depression they were poor uh and I mean
everybody was poor but they were poor
I'm like one generation removed from the
ghetto and what that has helped me and I
didn't realize this until I was older
like having that in the rear view you
know in the near rear view mirror
um was helpful to understand how things
continue to get better and how much how
much worse they could be how much better
they can be my kids are living a life at
least materially that is like you know
was literally unimaginable by me as a
kid and it's kind of great and you know
recognizing that progress uh both
material progress and moral progress
these are not things that have to happen
it's a choice
um and you know what are the what are
the ways that help make that happen you
know that have worked in the past that
have worked in the present and kind of
you know keeping an eye on history is
really important because I think to the
extent that we stay like mired in these
small like inch by inch you know kind of
battles over no man's land in every
election in every news cycle all of this
if we're not thinking about Transcendent
values or where we want to be you know
then it's just every day is a slug Fest
and it's just like you know you're stuck
in trench trench warfare from World War
One or something it's meaningless
um so I think history you know and again
that's not particularly libertarian I
mean people will interpret history in
different ways but it gives a sense of
perspective which is oftentimes the the
main thing that's lacking in debates
over virtually everything
yeah I agree especially that there that
there has to be both of these the
contending with history and what could
go wrong and kind of like the the
villains especially again coming off the
past couple years like we need to that
should be a reminder of how things can
backslide because that really was kind
of an experimentation experiment in like
what happens if we Central suddenly
centralize or politicize a lot of these
processes that were left to the market
and the outcome was not good and we
don't want that um so that should be
criticized and and uh you know to some
degree demonized but when you demonize
things when all you talk about is you
know the evil coveted regime and
everything like that but you're not
offering like here is
um you know the the this is where we can
be going and here are some concrete
examples that is what is is uh sometimes
lacking and sometimes much much harder
because it's it's easier to focus on an
on an enemy
um but much harder to sketch out that
positive Vision because then you
actually have to answer
um the critics of of what you're
sketching out there
um but yeah I think that's probably a
good place to leave it
um and I think I want to thank Camille
for uh joining us today thanks for the
talk again Nick and uh we'll see thanks
for everyone who left comments uh sorry
we didn't get to all of them but we'll
including sketch therapy who believes
that CRT is a combination of sexual
Market Marxism and racial Marxism
but not class-based Marxism why not why
not why not economic Marxism yeah
well thanks everyone we'll see you next
week